hi everyone I'm jeevana hecti a machine
learning and artificial intelligence
specialist customer engineer and I'm
Hussein Jiva a college technical
resident
welcome back to the technical series for
startups where we are creating a series
of videos for technical enablement to
help startups to start build and grow
their businesses successfully and
sustainably on Google cloud in our
previous video we talked about machine
learning apis which is a subsection of
all the machine learning offerings of
Google cloud and today we are going to
dive a little bit more on the machine
learning side of things we'll start by
looking at the four broad categories of
machine learning offerings on Google
Cloud
we will then go over understanding the
vertex AI platform we will then get into
some depth to understand automl in
vertex AI as well as custom modeling in
vertex AI
yeah I benefited one of our many many
customers
and now without any further Ado let's
get right on to the video
so Google cloud has several machine
learning offerings for you
but as an organization it's important to
understand your priority in terms of
speed as in how fast you want to get
started how much effort you want to put
in and the level of complexity and
customizability required
hence based on these we divide our ml
options into a few broad categories
starting with ML apis that you learned
about in the previous video
here you get started very quickly with
minimal effort and no amount of
customizability but suppose you need a
little more customization and you're
ready to put in some time and effort
before you get started we have something
called vertex AI in automl this is for
four types of data whether your data is
text Data thoroughly data images or
videos automl works for you the third
option is if you have ml experts in your
team putting in a lot of effort into
building a model for very specific needs
and you require a very customizable
platform
for that we have vertex AI with custom
models
this way you can have custom building to
training and deployment on a unified
platform that we provide
this would fairly take your time to
build to fit best with your complex use
cases
with bigquery ML or bqml you can stream
in your data or if you have your data
already stored in the bigquery data
warehouse even in petabyte scale you can
simply create your descriptive or
predictive ml models using bqml with
simple SQL queries this also takes some
time and effort but provides you with
great customizability
essentially we have a range of options
but the idea is to understand your
priorities and help you transform to an
AI company now with knowing where vertex
AI fits in in the broader mlai aspect
let us help you understand a little more
on what it is vertex AI is an umbrella
of machine learning products and
services for building training deploying
managing as well as scaling your machine
learning workloads
ml workflow from data Readiness to
feature engineering to hyperparameter
tuning to training serving the trained
model understanding it and tuning it
further deploying it to Edge case
devices like your mobile phones
monitoring your model scaling it and the
overall management we have products to
solve for each of these this diagram
right here gives you a quick lookbook of
which tools solve for which of this
purpose in this unified platform we'll
be covering a few of these in a little
more detail in just a bit
so vertex AI essentially gives you this
unified experience
it provides various options that we
discussed which are your ml apis automl
custom model training and your bigquery
ml in a single place
and because it's an integrated platform
your models can be reused pipelines can
be built to automate things and create a
workflow and so on
and this unified platform is built on
top of Google's robust secure Foundation
to create a CMOS experience and to
provide flexibility for users of all
levels of ml expertise whether you're
new to ml domain or an expert now let's
go ahead and understand Auto ml in a
little more detail
this is how your traditional ml workflow
looks like you load your data set
pre-process it to appropriate formats do
feature engineering on them then you
build your actual ml model deploy it and
it ultimately makes the predictions for
you
with automl we are helping you skip a
major chunk of this process with
pre-built models
so you simply load your data and it is
processed you need to set your training
budgets and automl will take care of the
rest for you but choosing the best fit
model and giving you the predictions so
you entirely skip having to choose your
model architecture actually having to
build your model and then tuning your
parameters and a lot of the other work
so this is essentially the fastest path
from data to Value we'll even look at a
quick demo for this very shortly
the way the product works is that we
provide a graphical codeless interface
guiding users through the end-to-end ml
life cycle with significant automation
as well as guard rails at each step
this will help you easily Define your
data schema and targets analyze your
input features in the feature statistics
dashboard and automatically train your
model including automated feature
engineering model selection and Hyper
parameter tuning automl automatically
search through Google's model Zoo to
find the best model for you and trains
your model
it will then allow you to evaluate your
model behavior before deploying to
production and then simply allow you to
deploy your model in one click
through this we can help you ensure that
what used to take months now can take
weeks or even days
when we say automat goes through module
Zoo what we
need our sets
an advanced deep Ensemble methods are
used for larger ones
Google's model portfolio includes
everything from feed forward DNN to deep
and wide neural network to gradient
booster decision trees and combinations
of multiple of these techniques and so
many many more so the benefit of
choosing this is that automl
automatically Cherry picks from the best
of research without you having to worry
about the research and deciding the best
way forward
now coming to custom modeling as
discussed this is for more complex and
Niche use cases that cannot be solved
with other ml
the idea is you define your instant
setup from uploading your training data
the data is extracted and you put it
into building your own model and
training it with the virtual Machines of
your choice of configuration
you have four pre-built container
options which are your pytorch
scikit-learn tensorflow and XT boost but
you can also put it in custom containers
and finally deploy your model and serve
it to test it with Cloud endpoints or
batch AI for batch predictions all these
from a single platform now without any
further ado let's head to the demo quick
note it's important to keep in mind that
you always need the required permissions
to access anything on the Google Cloud
console via console or the command line
interface
now let's begin
first I start by opening vertex AI on
the console
as you can see there are a bunch of
different tabs to the left right here
let's start by looking at the data set
section here it gives you the list of
the data sets already created if you've
done so or you can go ahead and create
one let's do that
click on create right here and then
choose what data type we want the
created data set to be as discussed
earlier this could be images tabular
data Text data or videos and you can
choose for what use case you're trying
to solve for right here so for example
under images you have single and
multi-able classification as well as
object detection and image segmentation
let me choose image classification for
single label for the purpose of this
demo and then quickly give it a name
now you have three options you can
choose to upload the files from your
computer upload imported files from your
computer or if you've already uploaded
your files to the Google Cloud Storage
you can simply import them right here
let me choose to upload files from my
computer and quickly upload a few you
also need to label your files for this
you can provide an annotation set or you
can simply do so once you've uploaded
your files on this platform
you can also choose your data split
right here as to how many files you
would want as part of training your
model while editing it and ultimately
testing your model you can also do this
data split at the time of model creation
and we'll look into that very shortly
while that's being done let me quickly
show you a data set which I've already
created for image classification
here you can see more than 5000 files
which have been labeled as either normal
lung X-ray scans or lungs affected by
pneumonia you can also see the data
split right here about 4 700 images were
used for training 541 files for
validation and 557 for testing quickly
coming back now we see that our data set
has been created now moving on to
training
this time right here shows your list of
models if you've tried creating any and
their statuses now let's go ahead and
create one
start by clicking on create here you get
to choose your data set and annotation
set the objective is blurred as we'd
already provided this input when we were
creating a data set
now here's where you choose your model
Training Method for vertex AI this could
be your automl or automl Edge in case
you want to export the automl model
being trained to your on-prem or mobile
device or so on or your custom Training
so I've selected our terminal Right Here
and Now moving on to model details here
I can choose to create a new model or
create a new version of an existing
model
then give it a name and description if
you like it
in the advanced options you have your
data split to choose between randomly
assigned or manual for training
validation and testing Additionally you
also have a check box to choose between
which encryption method you want to go
for now I'm just going to leave it all
as it is for the purpose of this demo
and click on start training now that's
how easy it is to get started on machine
learning on Google cloud with automl
now moving on to custom Training let's
go ahead and try and create one you
start by clicking on create again and
follow the same steps for choosing the
data set but this time you choose custom
Training for your training method
now we have additional tabs pop up to
the left right here the model details
and the advanced options are pretty much
the same as before Additionally you can
enable debugging by clicking on this
checkbox in case you want to be able to
debug your model even when training
which can be super helpful
then you choose your training container
this could be from a set of pre-built
containers that are already available or
you can choose to bring in your own
container I am going for the pre-built
option right here and choosing my model
framework and version then I need to
choose the path to the application code
which needs to be stored prior to this
in the Google Cloud Storage bucket so I
simply choose the path right here
then we choose the python module please
note that these are all very random
files just to show you the next steps as
mentioned earlier you can perform
hyperparameter tuning do so by checking
on this box now choose the parameter the
data type the Min and Max values and how
you want to be scaled then you actually
choose the metric for it to be optimized
and what the ultimate goal is to
minimize maximize and so on then you
choose the maximum number of Trials this
is it similarly you can add multiple
hyper parameters for it to be tuned in
I'm going to leave it as it is and move
on
now here's where you can choose your
machine types with which your model is
going to be trained you can opt for high
memory High GPU Mega GPU and so on you
can also choose to add accelerators like
tpus and gpus for heavy long running
jobs
and similarly you can choose to add more
worker pools and finally you can add
your production container which is
optional and simply click on start
training
just a few clicks away to get started
even with custom Training yay
now let me quickly demo an auto ml model
which I've already created to show you
the capabilities of vertex AI this is
for the x-rays dataset that we saw
earlier to classify whether a person has
been diagnosed with pneumonia or not
this right here is my model so when I
click on this you get to see a bunch of
different details right here is the
Precision and recall curve as well as
the confusion Matrix itself
you can see how many times the image was
normal and was classified as normal
versus wrongly predicted as pneumonia
Etc so you have your true positives true
negatives false positives and negatives
which essentially give you the accuracy
of the model
now I can simply deploy my trained model
to an endpoint to actually test it out
and because we already have an end point
let's simply go ahead and test this
model out I'm going to upload an image
of a normal lung X-ray scan let's see
what it classifies it as you can see
here that the model did a great job and
predicted it as normal now let me go
ahead and upload a pneumonia lung scan
now let me go ahead and upload a
pneumonia affected x-ray this was a
simple illustration of how a
classification use case can be solved
using our machine learning capabilities
on Google Cloud so without any further
Ado go create all the magic you want to
by leveraging this platform
with such powerful AI portfolio no
wonder many customers use it to speed up
their AIML workflows and expand their
capabilities
one of them is fertile mdcina this
Brazilian startup is a digital
Healthcare company that provides
reliable fast and low-cost Diagnostics
in Brazil and Africa
we'll talk to lmdcina uses ml models to
evaluate the contents of exams classify
the findings with the rescore and notify
the medical team about the patient's
condition
by utilizing vertex Ai and tensorflow
portal mdcina has improved ml diagnostic
reliability from 68 to 90 percent
with the transition to Google Cloud lmd
Cena has decreased to 20 to 30 minutes
down from two weeks their deployment
cycle
while spending 20 percent less when
compared to previous Cloud providers
as stated by portulentisina's CEO
the Google Cloud haml engine gave us
much more flexibility to create and tune
our ml models compared to the other
cloud services
in this session we understood the
various machine learning offerings of
Google cloud and understood vertex AI
we also Deep dive into automl and custom
models in vertex Ai and also saw a
Hands-On demo and finally also reviewed
a customer success story
if you're interested in learning more
please click on the links in the
description where you'll be able to read
up more on vertex AI check out our AI
simplified YouTube playlist and get
hands on the platform by trying out
step-by-step guided tutorials and please
reach out and get connected to learn
more
and that brings us to the end of this
session
in our next video we'll go over
understanding API Management in detail
which includes understanding what API is
why you need API management and choosing
between API Gateway and apogee
and that's a wrap don't forget to like
And subscribe to our YouTube channel
click on the Bell icon to get notified
each time a new video is posted
site and we'll see you very soon in our
next video
[Music]